the first table above shows a number of
premium members at two video rental
stores a number of premium members and
then the cyst or a in-store be during
the years two thousand to two thousand
to the second table shows the average
arithmetic mean number of video rentals
/ premium member at store be during each
of those years based on this information
which of the following best approximates
the total number of video rentals viola
movers underlying this the total number
of video rentals buy premium members at
store be during the years 2000 of 2002
so we want to consid can we want to
concern ourselves with store be between
2000 and 2002 so let's think about it a
little bit in the year 2000 how many
total rentals would there have been well
in the year 2000 you have 500 premium
members you have 500 premium members and
on average they each rented 12 12
rentals per year so the total number of
rentals / premium member is going to be
500 x 500 x 12 and you might be sing a
Sal look not all of them rented exactly
12 but you have to realize this average
is actually is actually created by
taking the sum of all of the 500s
rentals and then dividing by 500 so if
you multiply by 500 again then you're
going to get the total number that were
rented let me let me just let me just
let me just clarify that for you so if
you took if you knew the total that we
rented total rented in 2000 well if you
divided that by 500 if you divide that
by 500 then you're going to get the
average you're going to get the average
that were rented / or the average videos
rented / premium member so then if you
multiply both sides of this by 500 x 500
you're going to get that the total
rented is 12 x 500 you could view it is
on average 12 videos were rented per
member
x 500 members and that's exactly what we
did right over there let me clear this
up so let me clear that up so now we
could think about the year 2001 so in
2000 2001 and it's the same logic you
have a thousand premium members and they
each rented on average 15 videos each so
it's going to be 1000 times 15 and then
finally in 2002 2002 you have 1,250
premium members and they each rented 20
videos each or on average 20 each so if
you sum these up what are you going to
get let's see 500 times 12 5 times 12 is
60 60 then you have two more zeros so
that's six thousand one thousand times
15 is 15,000 and then let's see 1,250
times 2 would be 2,500 but then you have
another zero so it's 25,000 25,000 you
add these all together and what is yet
6,000 plus 15000 is twenty-one thousand
plus 25,000 is equal to 46 46 thousand
which is choice B choice be right over
there